hello my fellow americans
with me as always is my anger translator
luther
hi now the first year of my second term
has been a challenge
cluster tonight i'd like to address the
concerns of the american people
over what they perceive as the u.s
government spying on their digital and
electronic activities
man you're awesome deluded
self-important mother
if you think we're interested in your
deeping at porn watching asses
i can assure you the american people we
are not reading every individual email
rather we're searching for key words
that would indicate a threat and don't
worry everybody those key words are not
girl on girl anal squirting
plopping plopping
what the is plopping your dirty mother
these key words
are being used amongst other things to
prevent terrorists from using weapons of
mass destruction
not prevent you from watching videos of
ass
destruction now these policies have
already foiled numerous terrorist plots
these are not the kind of plots that
y'all are used to like when a guy comes
in the door with his penis in a pizza
box and a lady sucks on it
and i assure you that the country's
gotten safer since the end of the bush
era and i ain't talking about the
president
these policies have allowed us to probe
and penetrate i know
no luther just what i'm trying to say is
that there have been numerous terrorist
cells
fingered luther okay luther why are you
trying to undermine the president with
your juvenile sexual innuendo
the average american has nothing to fear
from these policies
now if we was drone striking perverts
our country would look like mad max
beyond thunderdome right about now
i'm talking about a post-apocalyptic
nightmare
thank you and good night go to sleep
y'all
plopping oh yeah sir when you oh
y'all are some sick mother
you